[Music]
[Applause]
how do you make Xi Jinping stop his
policy of confrontation with Democratic
countries once and for all how on Earth
can we prevent the totalitarian regime
in Beijing from becoming a risk and a
threat to everyone visualpolitic viewers
today more than ever these questions are
extremely topical
China has undergone an enormous change
after Decades of rapid growth and
technological productive and Military
modernization XI jinping's regime is now
obsessed with one idea to turn China
into the new world leader a superpower
capable of rivaling the United States
they want to put an end to the dominance
of the West in order to make Beijing the
new international Benchmark capital
precisely for this reason under
Communist Party rule China is trying to
increase its political economic military
and even cultural influence so what's
the problem that China is still a
totalitarian dictatorship and that
should concern us all especially when Xi
Jinping is developing an increasingly
hostile agenda do you want some examples
well let's see
[Music]
there's the case of the Chinese balloon
that flew over the United States which
was discovered while flying over a
nuclear ballistic missile facility in
Montana a balloon which was eventually
destroyed by an F-22 and apparently
carried antennas and sensors for
Gathering intelligence and intercepting
Communications in fact as confirmed by
the U.S Department of State the balloon
manufacturer itself has a direct
relationship with the Chinese military
Chinese balloon carried antennas other
equipment to gather intelligence U.S
says U.S preparing to take action
against entities tied to Chinese balloon
surveillance program official says Hans
to top it all off we've learned that
this is not an isolated case we now know
that we can find many more cases
apparently it is a fleet of alleged spy
balloons and devices operating in the
five continents including as we've seen
the United States which is a clear
concern of course balloons are not the
most dangerous or troubling aspect of
Chinese Espionage cyber attacks are much
worse and you know what they've been so
prevalent for years that FBI director
James Comey himself joked in 2014 that
there are two types of large companies
in the United States those that have
been hacked by the Chinese and those
that don't know they've been hacked by
the Chinese
you see Chinese cyberspires have
systematically attacked the United
States by stealing blueprints industrial
designs Trade Secrets and all kinds of
confidential information from the US
government and U.S companies they've
even got their hands on classified
material for such important designs as
the F-35 which as you can imagine does
not make anyone in Washington Terribly
Happy do you remember when the US
government stopped buying Huawei devices
and asked U.S companies not to use their
products well this was exactly the
reason as it stands the growing clash
between China the United States and the
community of liberal democracies goes
far beyond Espionage beijing's
confrontational agenda is also behind
news stories like this one China AIDS
Russia's war in Ukraine trade data shows
despite sanctions Moscow equips its Jets
Fighters submarines and Soldiers with
help from Chinese companies China has
not only supported the sanctions but as
a gesture it is sending Russia among
other components navigation equipment
for Russian m17 helicopters
Communications jamming equipment and
parts that could be used in su-35
Fighters all this however in small
quantities and why do we say that this
is a kind of provocation
well because and this is the most
interesting thing it is not a question
of massive shipments if China wanted to
it could Supply Russia with large
quantities of weapons if it wanted to
but as we've already said here on
visualpolitik it does not seem that they
want to and risk a massive clash with
the West so what they seem to be doing
is sending equipment that allows them to
save face with Moscow while marking
their distance from the United States
the European Union and the rest of their
allies to this end they are mainly
sending dual use equipment that is
equipment that could be used for both
military and civilian purposes be that
as it may that is helping Russia and
what's more it is a gesture that makes
it very very clear that tomorrow its
position could change in any case it is
yet another defined gesture and no we
are not done yet
then we have what happened with Hong
Kong and above all the constant threats
against Taiwan threats that have
multiplied in recent years and that have
even LED senior U.S and military
officials to warn that an invasion of
the island could take place much sooner
than anyone could have imagined
spy balloons cyber attacks collaboration
with Russia occupation of Hong Kong and
constant threats to Taiwan and also many
other countries such as Lithuania the
result is that XI jinping's agenda has
given China a much more active and
hostile foreign policy with what we
might call the Free World so the
question is what on Earth can be done to
stop Beijing what measures could the
United States take to punish or prevent
this type of situation and keep in mind
this is no minor question it is one of
the most important questions of our time
and guess what this is where the
sanctions hypothesis comes in could XI
jinping's imperialist agenda be stopped
with economic sanctions is this the best
way to confront the Asian giant in this
video we will answer these questions but
first of all what exactly are we talking
about listen up
economic punishment
our economic sanctions really useful and
effective and do they serve any purpose
this is not a new debate it's been going
on for at least 2 500 years in fact one
of the first economic sanctions packages
on record is known as the decree of
magara in 432 BC a lot of time has
passed since then with this decree
Athens banned trade with magara and
prohibited the merchants of the latter
City from accessing Athenian ports which
for many was the main cause that sparked
the Peloponnesian War
[Music]
a much more recent example was when the
League of Nations sanctioned Italy in
1935 for the invasion of the Ethiopian
region of abyssinia a few years later
the United States did the same with the
Empire of Japan and with Germany of the
Third Reich but above all sanctions
began to gain more and more influence
from the 1950s onward and multiplied in
particular following the September 11th
attacks from apartheid South Africa to
the Iran of the ayatollahs Via Isis Kim
jong-un's Korea the Gaddafi regime and
even the Cali cartel
[Music]
in this graph you can clearly see how
economic punishments have become more
and more popular of course I'm sure this
comes as no surprise to anyone these
economic punishments have been led by
the United States taking advantage of
the global influence of both the dollar
and its own Financial system
this is the charge that brings together
U.S sanctions against countries
companies and individuals from all
corners of the globe look at how it has
evolved in the last 20 years and of
course if we include 2022 the graph
would go even higher because of course
as you all know the last major massive
sanctions program is precisely the one
that has to do with Putin's Russia after
the invasion of Ukraine now the question
is do they work well it depends on how
you look at it in a past video here on
visualpolitik we already showed you how
the sanctions on Russia were achieving
very significant achievements although
we have the feeling that they have not
yet managed to topple the Russian
economy in fact in order to avoid major
damage to the global economy sanctions
are often targeted at very specific
areas in other words they can almost be
seen as surgical strikes that is the
trend in recent years at least in the
case of Russia without going any further
we're talking about strikes against its
Financial system government revenues its
technological and Military industry and
foreign investment in this way what is
being done is to try to cause as much
damage as possible in the medium term
without bursting for for example the
global energy Market that is also why a
price cap on Russian oil was fixed
instead of banning all trade in Russian
oil but wait a minute because let's see
talking about China and sanctions is not
like talking about Russia North Korea
Iran or practically any other country
talking about China is serious serious
talk so the question is can China really
be sanctioned and if it could be done
would it be any good well let's take a
look
[Music]
can China be sanctioned
the United States and China are getting
along worse than at any other time in
recent decades practically since Richard
Nixon said in motion the political four
back in 1972 things have not been going
this badly between these two countries
and this despite the fact that the
economies of these two Giants are much
closer together than at any other time
in history look at this U.S China trade
hit record in 2022 despite tensions
we're talking about a gigantic trade
volume of just over
690 billion dollars and perhaps
precisely because of this in recent
years one question is getting all the
Limelight if economic relations are so
important can China be sanctioned could
economic Warfare be used to weaken the
Asian giant and get Xi Jinping and his
Clique to desist from such a hostile
agenda well take note because this in a
way is exactly what is being done
it started with Donald Trump's famous
and very poorly thought out trade war
and now the Biden Administration is
following in much the same footsteps
especially when it comes to technology
for example on 16th of September 2022
Joe Biden's National Security adviser
Jake Sullivan gave a major speech in
which he changed the United States
strategic objectives from betting on
maintaining a certain relative advantage
over its Rivals basically China to
wanting to make that Advantage as big as
possible and so the U.S national
security strategy is no longer limited
to wanting to lead but now in terms of
technology and with respect to China it
hopes above all too overwhelm it wants
to be far ahead whatever the cost and
that's what explains new stories like
this Laden Administration clamps down on
China's access to chip technology the
White House issued sweeping restrictions
on selling semiconductors and Chip
making equipment to China in an attempt
to curb the country's access to critical
Technologies U.S aims to curtail
technology investment in China the bade
Administration is preparing new rules
that would restrict U.S dollars from
flowing to China we're talking about the
type of measures that have recently been
strengthened take a look Japan and the
Netherlands joined U.S chip curbs to
China these are the three countries that
currently dominate the production of
high-end chip manufacturing equipment so
in a way this is a sanction the United
States is preventing the sale to China
of the designs and production of the
most advanced microchips and also of the
machines that allow these microchips to
be manufactured and this is extremely
important
China's leading domestic chip maker smic
produces chips that are several
Generations behind the Leading Edge of
the market smic currently makes 14
nanometer chips and has recently said it
may make small quantities of seven
nanometer chips to give you an idea
taiwan's tsmc and Samsung are already
widely making five and three nanometer
chips a five nanometer microchip is
approximately three times faster or more
efficient than a 14 nanometer chip
and naturally for China to reach that
level it needs the machines that allow
such production for example the extreme
ultraviolet lithography Machines
manufactured by the Dutch company asml
the most advanced company in the world
in this field but now China will no
longer be able to buy such technology
this could delay its Plans by a decade
or more these are sanctions that are
already in place but the question is
could or should they go much further if
for example Xi Jinping continues to
advance his hostile agenda or even takes
action against Taiwan what is the Biden
Administration really pursuing with this
policy well let's take it one step at a
time
[Music]
as you can see on the screen there are
several types of sanctions but as far as
we are concerned the two most important
ones the two that would make the most
sense and have the most impact would be
Financial sanctions and Export controls
for example the export controls on
technological Goods that we have already
seen regarding Financial sanctions the
United States could threaten to freeze
China's assets as it has done with
Russia China has just over three
trillion dollars in reserves in the
United States and with other U.S allies
however in the medium term this could be
a very very bad idea firstly because it
would reduce the attraction of capital
in addition China could react by
confiscating Western investments in
their country we are talking according
to data from the center for strategic
and international studies about 3.6
trillion dollars in direct investment
and 2.2 trillion dollars in stocks bonds
and similar products then another type
of financial sanctions would be to cut
off their bank's operations with
International Banks that would be
something like the nuclear option the
problem is that this would sink trade
with China if you can't pay for the
exchange of goods then logically they
are are not going to happen even
introducing minor restrictions such as
the Swift exclusion would have a
considerable impact for China but also
for the Western countries themselves
which would suddenly find themselves
with a huge shortage of all kinds of
products it would be total chaos many
Western companies would just collapse
and inflation would go through the roof
keep in mind that China is the world's
largest exporter and produces as much
stuff as the United States and Europe
combined so no it does not sound like a
very good idea and that leads directly
to trade sanctions to tariffs and import
restrictions
[Music]
well tariffs are not very efficient and
Western consumers end up paying the
price and the bill in fact according to
the New York fed estimates Trump's
tariffs cost an average of eight hundred
and thirty dollars per year per U.S
household so that leaves us with only
two possible measures two much more
gradual and surgical measures to
progressively reduce China's presence in
international production chains the
problem is that this is a very long and
very slow process so above all the
option is to restrict the Asian Giant's
access to certain Imports but here you
have to be very selective because
China's factories have to continue
producing and in addition conflict
should be avoided at all costs let's not
forget that China is a nuclear power
with very clear plans China is
considering tripling its stockpile of
nuclear warheads to 900 by 2035 as
tensions with the United States are
expected to escalate further over Taiwan
so blocking their oil supply for example
would not make much sense it would slow
down Chinese production create a global
crisis and perhaps even a military crash
that's why we have to be much more
selective is it a problem that China is
the world's Factory no if anything the
problem is that it is a world-class
technological power and you know what
China is still very dependent in this
respect
yes China exports a lot but it also
devours a huge amount of products from
abroad in addition to oil its main
Imports are microchips and other
Advanced technological products and who
are its main suppliers well I can tell
you that Japan South Korea the United
States Taiwan Germany and a few other
Western countries dominate the vast
majority of China's technology Imports
therefore restricting access to
cutting-edge technology could be a
severe blow to XI jinping's Ambitions
without jeopardizing China's current
role in the global economy not having
access to cutting-edge technology could
for instance limit the Asian Giant's
military capabilities and yes that is
exactly what explains the Biden
administration's strategy and Technology
constraints have you ever thought about
it
[Music]
and so to summarize can China be
sanctioned generally speaking no the
remedy could turn out to be just as
worse as the disease chaos would be
widespread let's just say that China's
role in the global economy has become
far too important what could be done
however is to slow down their
development by preventing their access
to cutting-edge Technologies and
products what's more this would cause
many companies to gradually move their
production lines out of China which in
the long term may be the best option so
as to not depend on the whims of Xi
Jinping or similar dictators to provide
Alternatives of course the problem is
that this requires taking measures as
soon as possible and not waiting for a
possible crash because in a short period
of time these measures would not be
effective
of course the United States and its
allies would also have to step on the
accelerator to speed up their own
technological development this would
likely require new incentives for
business and investment an active
government policy and a much more open
door for attracting International talent
and yes China could try to catch up but
the problem is that it is still far
behind It suffers from a huge Talent
drain and the weight of large public
companies which are much less Innovative
than private ones is growing again in
other words this strategy could actually
work and even if it does not dissuade
the Chinese government from its agenda
it could at least limit its ability to
maneuver this is at least what they seem
to think in Washington and what explains
the latest U.S moves but at this point
the questions are all over to you do you
think this is a good strategy do you
think China's access to Western
technology should be further restricted
would this be a good enough response to
Xi Jinping how might the Chinese
government react leave us your
impressions in the comments and let's
open up a debate now if you found this
video interesting don't forget to like
And subscribe to visualpolitik if you
have not already done so all the best
I'll see you next time
[Music]
foreign